I've been talking about this for years
and it's getting closer and closer it's
what I call deathless meat or as some
like to call it lab-grown meat there's a
company called the Memphis meats among
others actually and they are about ready
to offer lab-grown meat to the masses as
soon as 2021 which is just under three
years from now a Bill Gates and Richard
Branson are some of the investors in
this company and they say that they have
already produced beef chicken and duck
directly from animal cells without
needing to raise and slaughter actual
animals and the way that it works is by
combining cells in tanks and bio
reacting it with other elements and
nutrients Memphis meats is doing this
there's also a company called the beyond
meat there's another one called
impossible foods that's working on the
same thing and this would address a lot
of the concerns that people have who
either don't eat meat or want to reduce
meat consumption if you don't like the
killing of animals it solves that if you
don't like the environmental impact of
raising animals and the water and food
consumption it solves that if you don't
like the possible or known health
concerns around eating too much meat it
actually addresses that because you can
create this meat without animals that
are eating antibiotics and possibly
breathing or eating contaminated air or
grass or grains or whatever so I guess
that would probably make it healthier as
well the main issue has actually been
price which is coming down drastically
the first time I reported on this I
think one burger had a cost of like 300
thousand dollars I reported on it again
three years ago the price was down to
the cost was down to ten to twelve
dollars that doesn't include you know
markup and shipping and warehousing and
everything else but that that was the
reduction that we saw would vegan Pat
eat lab-grown deathless me yeah I think
I would I mean I would at least try it
now my taste buds have recalibrated for
at this point and I don't really crave
meat so much your soy boy now as oh yeah
as the hay tree it's like this I'm such
a soy boy at this place but what I do
think is that those
to eat a standard American diet yeah it
would be a good way for them to
transition and sir like more of a vegan
vegetarian approval no doubt about it
and I've said before I believe that the
consumption of meat from raised and
slaughtered animals is going to become
more and more niche over time it's very
hard to imagine in 50 years still
raising and slaughtering animals for me
oh the way we do now I mean it seems
totally unlikely right it's
unsustainable too it's the land the
water we don't have the resources I'm
not sure about eliminated like it might
become a very luxury good we're like in
50 years if you have actual real animals
that have been slaughtered for meat it
would be sort of a novelty in some way I
don't know if it'll go away but it's
going to be reduced drastically and this
I think is probably a pretty good path
forward in hunting will still be around
I mean if you live off the grid you have
no choice but to go kill your food yeah
but most of us live within the general
vicinity of a grocery store and have no
need for eating meat at this point an
interesting question I saw online was
could the process by which this meat is
created in a lab be miniaturized so that
in the future you could have a home
machine and you create your meat
on-demand
right before you cook it or something
like that yeah I don't like like making
her own beer sure or you know growing
your own vegetables in the backyard that
kind of thing same type of thing yeah
yeah now out of curiosity would it be
okay or ethical or moral or taboo to
grow meat for animals you wouldn't
normally eat like for example a lot of
people don't eat whale oils are smart
social whatever right a lot of people
say I don't eat whale even though some
countries eat whale I would never eat
whale would that apply to lab-grown
whale or would that eliminate all of
those problem I don't know because I
think people draw the line at a very
weird spot like most people say that
it's okay to eat cows and chickens and
pigs but it's not okay to eat dogs and
cats I know that you don't well it
depends on what country right and some
yeah it's different but yeah it depends
on the culture but I just say we
shouldn't kill any animals altogether so
I don't have that same moral dilemma
about eating a whale you know I'm
increasingly thinking that there is
going to be we're getting off topic but
crisis in the vegan community over the
fact that we are learning more and more
about plants that panic in a way that is
reminiscent of sentience and bivalves
that seem to have less quote sentience
than some plants I think that is
definitely going to be not that I'm
worried about it but an upcoming crisis
well vegan community first I would want
to see that these plants feel pain and
also if you want to eliminate or reduce
plants suffering right you still want to
go for that vegan or vegetarian approach
because then you don't have to filter
all those plants through animals because
the animals are eating the plants first
and then people eat the animals the
animals are eating the plants and then
people like to get a cow or a chicken or
a pig to its size it's got to eat soy
and it's gonna eat alfalfa and all these
different plants right to get it to the
size that it is yeah raise that two
thousand pound animal right and so but
but okay we'll follow up on this on the
plants would be eaten yes in the chief
that it's more in the environmental
impact aspect of it send me your
thoughts on this would you eat lab-grown
I don't know meat
chimpanzee or something like that what
would be the ethics of that